chemistry phd in cosmetic chemists here  there are a lot of myths and  fear-mongering about the ingredients and  cleanses called surfactants which are  what gets the oils and dirt off your  skin specifically sulfates  first off sodium lauret sulfate is sles  not sls sodium laureth sulfate is  actually a gentle surfactant than a lot  of the ones in sulfate-free cleanses  secondly even sodium lauryl sulfate sls  which is harsher can be made gentle by  combining it with other surfactants like  cocomidopropyl propobatein which you can  actually see on some of these labels it  forms something called a mixed micelle  which keeps the sls out of your skin and  cuts down on irritation  at the end of the day if a cleanser  makes your skin feel nice keep using it  whether it's sls free or not